the beach attack is happening killers
l14 res G has just entered the hotel
grounds he's looking for targets there's
utter confusion
he's shooting and more some type of bomb
remarkably the staff keep moving forward
trying to find the killer total
disregard for their own safety
then quiet watch closely now the
cameraman picks up a bottle from the bar
he can see res G he's thinking of
attacking him res she walks in front of
him just yards away his machine gun in
the air
the cameraman back tracks before
following him towards the sea he's
utterly shocked it's silent save for his
breathing and the occasional gasp he's
in a daze walking through this words
can't really describe what he must have
been thinking there's bodies everywhere
others start arriving and they spot the
killer on the beach
failure to do so fake tattoos and to get
some blood look at Uggla yeah yeah
he's still armed but they chase anyway
our cameraman who cuts through a beach
club it is now just behind the fleeing
gunman as fighting between him and the
police intensify the terrorist is only
just in front of them but they refuse to
give up
[Music]
moments later residue is dead a
remarkable film and remarkable bravery
mr. Ramsay sky news
June is here